all right you want to talk about elliott
page excuse me oh yeah elliot page damn
near transformed into pete davidson
seen this picture bro she yoked here she
did she the
queen of staten island bro yo you got to
look at
who did this surgery yo whoever did this
surgery i'm seeing
i'm tired of working out no no my man
did it what do you mean it's
fit no no he his body is amazing dude's
got abs bro
abs bruh full blown and you seen her
titties
that's juno's titties bro but what do
they do with those
what what do they do with them you can
put them in each app
oh they do fat transfer oh it's it's so
you want to know some crazy things the
abs that you see these like
instagram [ __ ] that you know how like
they got abs now like cardi b got abs
but it's sculpted
they stretch the obliques and then it
gives you uh
definition on the side my oh is that
what they do yeah so they have the one
if they have definition on the side they
take the oblique and
stretch it down so then it makes it pop
out a little bit that's crazy yo
i was under the impression that they do
fat transfers
so that they look like abs but if you
touch them they're not hard at all no no
it's actually muscle i was told
otherwise so they get they get the fat
transfer so they take the fat out so now
you make the weight small
yeah you take part of your oblique
muscle you cut it
stretch it so now it's like more tight
like it's totally
yeah and so now your muscles always tone
yeah botox media knows a lot about
surgeries bro
don't they stretch your calves why they
ever try doing that
they stretch your calves up a little bit
no i gotta go i need implants at this
point
yo if you're gonna do it do it i kind of
respect this from elliot page like i
don't give a [ __ ] about your
like sex or gender or whatever the [ __ ]
you always want to tell people about
but if you're gonna do it if you're
gonna transition um
do it pop out that [ __ ] did it
yeah
you know he went in we we see people
half-ass their transition
yeah and you just look stupid right
you just do it looks dumb yeah but if
you go all in
burn the boats get the abs burn the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] boats burn the boats
bruh
yeah but he couldn't wait to show that
picture because the the [ __ ]
titty surgery scar wasn't even healed
yet he still had stitches in and
everything
he's like now you're gonna see these abs
ads yeah i couldn't even notice that so
the question is is he a [ __ ] boy now is
he he looked like a [ __ ] neck tattoo
he really does man this is he i think he
gotta lean all the way in he's a
he's a dj now that [ __ ] is that
might be a chainsmoker
he turned into a chain smoker bro yo
this is how good the surgery is
we calling this [ __ ] he yeah we never
do that you gotta have respect for
somebody that's fit yo
everybody's out here teaching the
peloton class probably
son it is unbelievable we got to talk to
muscle doc see what he's on yeah
because you know he's on some sort of
testosterone steroids some [ __ ]
oh man i'm honestly convinced he got a
pecker bruh
oh i think he done grown out of pecker
i think he done grown out of pecker bro
he did it huh
i need to see elliot page's penis bruh
i want to see it i would like to see it
i if the body looks that good imagine
the penis
the abs on the dick oh okay
come on zany as [ __ ] yes central vain
looking like a white ray j dick
elliot page about to smash your girl
dick bench 250. yeah easy i made my own
follow
you did yes machine gun elliott
yo watch out for machine gun ellie bro
machine gun ellie is coming for your
[ __ ] yeah you can follow ellen page
you can't follow elliott
are you crazy uh uh no i don't stand for
it i gotta see the thing he's slanging
right
i think he's slanging the thang thing
i think he got a nice little hog pick
that [ __ ] out
fresh yeah if you were if you transition
if you went from female to male
what would i get how big exactly what i
had
no what would i what would i go with
color thickness or length all the above
okay definitely
pakistani i'm not i can't go brown bro
i would go i would go pink dude i do
like
ninja turtle pink like super pink see it
in the dark
pink like you see it in the dark like
reflective or reflective
hot pink i go hot pink okay hot pink and
then
girth like dog would you get dog say
what like dogs oh dog lipstick yeah
uh yeah you get a dog i do dog lipstick
and i had the head a different color
i would have the shaft pink and the head
would be
um yeah when are we gonna get to
designer dicks i like this you can do it
now elliot got one bro yeah
she's out there what do you think it
looks like mushroom
that should look like a portabello son i
think she got the
fat hood bro i think i think put it on a
burger nom nom nom
nom dude real talk yeah she got the
impossible meat
[Music]
can we call [ __ ] dick's impossible me
[Laughter]
can we do that yeah we call it johnny
dick's impossible meat from now on
i need to see elliot's impossible meat i
need to see kaitlyn's impossible me
i need to see where these surgeries are
at
that's only fair wait can we get the
surgery
if we see it and it's good enough we
might as well well like we're allowed to
right
lop it off put in another one
you've never seen how the spaceship is
connected i got the pump pump say what
you got the pump i don't want a pump
bruh
i want my dick hard always you think
it's hard all the time i want it that's
how i want it
always hard default is hard i see mad
uncomfortable no it's not
nothing with something that you wish
i'll flip it up to the belly the only
time it's uncomfortable is that the
urinal for the people next to me mm-hmm
because i'm gonna pee up like that and
then down to the one next to me yeah
over the over the wall
not even over the wall i'm gonna go flat
you're gonna like this
and then write down parabola so the
person's gonna go to this one but no no
i'm using that one he's like what are
you talking about
he is impressive dawg no it's like the
bellagio yes
yes yeah i like that bellagio pissing
i'm hitting that ballast
synchronized you know what i mean you
and the homie get there you shoot
across streams i watch that show i mean
come on
is that weird that i want to see elliot
paige's penis bro
why is that weird you want to see
women's vaginas
yeah what's wrong with seeing ellie and
paige's pee pee
that's the thing right you don't want to
see caitlyn jenner's vagina bro
i said i'm all about seeing vaginas you
don't want to see that penis you're the
only person who watches porn to see
for dicks like i don't watch it
exclusively no you
said that you you searched the dicks
that's not
i've never searched the pawn for the
dick no no no i'm not gonna not watch a
porn with a girl
just because the dick is trash but if
the dick is to my liking i will enjoy it
more yeah
duh no but yo
[Laughter]
agreed